all right so you've decided to play
Destiny 2. oh wait a minute
didn't we do this already
looks like we've been here before if
this is your first time welcome if this
is not welcome back allow me your humble
host to guide you through the best part
of the destiny cycle maximum height yes
this is the time where every trailer
Bungie puts out is an absolute Banger
every YouTuber drowned content has even
longer interest to read through and a
certain Lore Master is furiously typing
away at a dock ready to bring another
side of Destiny's excellent story to
life he got new powers to discover new
weapons to earn or craft you get to fly
to Neptune in a retro cyberpunk style
metropolis and face off against the new
Legion of enemies and just like last
year in a time where other shooter games
are rebuilding or growing a bit stale
Destiny comes back like the Giga chat it
is and we are here for it Destiny 2
lightfall is basically Destiny 2 but at
one of the most climactic eras in the
destiny world if you're new your journey
starts here same goes for you lapse folk
that left at some point for one reason
or another Destiny is a live service
shared shooter world full of action RPG
and MMO elements combined together with
activities for well everyone there's a
story and a very good story at that
which can range from easy to follow and
uh not so easy but let's get you caught
up on what's changed so you just woke up
on Russia and you're asking
what's going on if you plan on playing
lightfall and want a quick catch up then
stick around but if you don't want to
have the major plot points of the red
War curse of Osiris War mind forsaken
Shadow keep Beyond light and the witch
queen and the seasons in between
revealed and skip to the next section of
this video using the timestamps alright
folks yeah ah Jesus Christ okay so the
important thing to know is that there's
a struggle you're constantly told about
between light and darkness The Traveler
symbolizes the light and you well you
are the guardian you were dead a long
time until your ghost found you and
resurrected you ghosts come from The
Traveler who made them as a last-ditch
effort to combat its mortal enemy
referred to Simply as the darkness every
Guardian started out with their own
ghost and they've got their own
personalities too but now you're almost
a certified Legend and are going to be
asked by Vanguard leaders vendors even
villains to do their bidding at times
all in the name of prosperity Mutual
benefit bits and very good loot in any
case in the world of light bearers as
Guardians are called we are currently in
the middle of a modern era we've
survived pandemics in a really dark time
in history known as the collapse which
came right after an era of massive
technological advancements during the
Golden Age so now we're just
kind of vibing
it's nice
at least we're trying to Vibe until a
psycho cabal Commander stole our [__]
and burned it all up the traveler
eventually woke up and destroyed the guy
but I also woke up something else
foreign
yeah it's called the black Fleet it's
basically a bunch of Darkness scary
Dorito ships on their way to annihilate
us which is basically base D2 or vanilla
as we call it now enter curse of Osiris
where a Vex hive mind tries to mess with
different timelines and a grumpy Phoenix
man called Osiris needs your help then
in warmind a tiny yes tiny if you could
believe it Hive God woke up under Mars
and then some smug [__] awoken Prince
murdered our hunter Vanguard leader in
Forsaken and that was just the first two
years
meanwhile Shadow key brings us back to
the moon it's literally haunted and one
of those scary ships is already here and
just like quietly watching us we go into
the ship face the nightmares of old
bosses and then face the darkness itself
for the first time which takes the form
of
us we start seeing the darkness far more
often in the Beyond light expansion
indirectly by embracing the power of
stasis we're not the only ones either
though as a group of Fallen enemies also
gained this power transforming
themselves into ruthless enemies that we
take out one by one the witch Queen
herself sabathune who has been working
behind the scenes since D1 is the center
of attention in the expansion of the
same name and it's here that we finally
put a name to the darkness in the leader
of the black Fleet the witness now
that's where we are now in lightfall
we've already struck down a disciple of
the witness and based on the lightfall
story trailers kallus a raid enemy from
vanilla G2 returns as another disciple
and we discovered the new subclass Power
known as strand letting us do a bunch of
stuff from unleashing Little infecting
threadlings to grappling around the neon
city of neomona the new setting where
lightfall's story takes place
it's set up to be the big showdown
between light and dark and another step
closer to the ultimate payoff of nearly
eight years of Destiny
Destiny 2 has three classes the Titan
Hunter and warlock there is no right
answer but if you specifically want the
cape that'll be the hunter for you truth
is in the early days we used to view
Titans as the typical tank Hunters as
like a lone wolf Rogue type and warlocks
as a support Mage class but really they
all can kind of interchange their roles
Hunters are really good at unleashing
just pure damage and are pretty squishy
but they can also make their teammates
go invisible or debuff enemies to help
raise the team's overall damage they're
also the typical Rogue stabby class
Titans do a lot of hammer swinging
punching bashing and crashing yes but
they can also be a stalwart Shield
Paving the way forward or can create a
nearly impenetrable bubble boosting
armor and damage for their team warlocks
are more than just the moms of the fire
team of course they Thrive at healing
and healing their teammates but they're
just as lethal in chaining damage
between enemies or unleashing massive
elements attacks on anyone in their path
you can make up to three characters and
most players have one of each class
here's a tip I'm going to give you that
I don't see people say often because
normally they just go oh punch equals
Titan or sneaking equals Hunter and blah
blah blah no the secret is to make each
character and then see which jump you
prefer trust me they all have different
jumps and everyone has a preference
Titans get a jet pack burst warlocks
have a long range Glide and hunters get
like two or three jumps in a row believe
me finding a jump you can gel with will
go a long way towards your enjoyment and
navigating the world of Destiny but I
will not fall to you if you go hunter
just for the cape cause
yeah they are pretty cool now this next
one really is the hardest question for
me to answer it is so confusing at times
because different players like different
things if you're in it for the story
you'll want to do your best to untangle
the past current and seasonal campaigns
in whichever order of your choosing if
you want to do dungeons and raids then
you'll want to get started immediately
on the power grinds and get strong gear
from well honestly anywhere at least at
first your best case is usually the
ritual activities which are the PVE
Vanguard strikes PVP Crucible and the
hybrid Gambit you'll be getting
different colored Loot and you'll want
to aim for having a whole set of purple
legendary weapons and armor which tend
to have the better stats in the game
mixed in with a couple of exotic gears
in your Loadout thankfully in lightfall
if you are a new player or even a
returning player that's forgotten how to
navigate Destiny we now have Guardian
ranks and your best bet is to go here
immediately and just follow whatever
suggestions it makes the idea is the
more familiar you become with the
systems in place in Destiny the easier
it will be to eventually start setting
content goals for yourself such as
getting ready for the end game content
or figuring out which activities give
you the rewards that you are interested
in now Solo versus Co-op is another
point of contention generally the rule
of thumb is that Destiny is better
played with friends it is a shared world
and the more people you play with the
more fun you potentially have I will
give a warning though you will most
likely have a far easier time navigating
with friends that are at the same level
as you because then you can discover the
world of Destiny together for yourselves
and everyone's on the same page the best
part is that there is a magic and a
mystery to all of this you will also be
more in sync on Quest steps especially
on older content which can be really
confusing now I'm speaking from
experience I've tried onboarding several
friends but it never quite worked out
since I operate off of habits and
systems that are now second nature to me
while they're still getting their sea
legs and navigating the dozens of
currencies menus Quest logs challenges
triumphs the battle pass you get what
I'm saying that being said unless you
are an introvert and overall solo gamer
you will still most likely have a better
time with friends than alone
it is also good to check the modifiers
or info on any activity as they'll give
you a rundown on important elements like
if matchmaking is active strikes PVP
Gambit and seasonal activities are all
match made but Nightfall strikes of a
certain difficulty level like legend or
higher Legend activities lost sectors
exotic missions Dungeons and raids they
don't have matchmaking so your mileage
will vary on how much fun you can have
in these activities alone for me
personally I am a solo campaign type of
guy fire Team friendly nearly everything
else it's just easier for my brain to
listen to story beats cut scenes and
read when I'm by myself but again to
each their own now one of the most
unpopular eras in Destiny was the sun
setting era where countless environments
activities campaigns and even weapons
were taken out of the game or rendered
Obsolete and activities where power
level is factored in when it comes to
content you can play that means the red
War curse of Osiris War mind and
forsaken campaigns have all been removed
entirely several seasons have also been
cycled out including the recent ones
leading up to the witch Queen and
lightfall expansions that being said you
can still play shadow keep space
campaign as well as Beyond lights you
can even still access the dreaming City
area which was part of forsaken all
relevant endgame Dungeons and raids are
also accessible from those expansions
with the exception of some exotic
missions such as Whisper of the worm and
outbreak perfected
the witch Queen is technically old
content now but with the exception of
the seasonal content you can also play
Everything the witch Queen offered if
you own the expansion now that we're
getting into the weed of things you
might be asking how do you get raid
ready the fastest way to get raid ready
now is to do the legendary campaign not
only are the drops super rewarding but
completing it will grant you a complete
armor set at the power level cap which
will be a massive boost unfortunately
unless you already have a pretty solid
Loadout doing the legendary campaign
will not be easy if you're starting out
therefore the best way in my mind is to
play what you want and keep an eye on
the number of the gear that drops for
you playlist activities are the way to
start popping some strikes go do the
seasonal activity and stash away any
gear you get from the chests your future
drops will weigh all the gear you
possess into account and you'll soon see
the loot you get drop at a higher and
higher level once you hit the power cap
the only way you can get higher drops is
by doing activities that specify that
they give you a powerful or even a
pinnacle reward then we say a prayer to
the RNG gods and hope that Whatever item
we get is in a slot that needs it you
also want to make sure you have solid
solid weapons at the level cap doesn't
really matter if your sidearm is at max
power level if it sucks right lately
linear Fusion rifles have been the
dominant weapon but they are getting
nerfed next season so if you're trying
to get older Exotics or really solid
ones to aim for first are arborist and
sleeper simulant which are absolved from
that linear Nerf I mentioned but then
also izanagi's burden or even Whisper of
the worm not just the start that way you
have at least one solid boss DPS weapon
so you're not completely throwing now
PVP is totally optional there are a
bunch of players that don't care for PVP
and only do it if they absolutely have
to for a particular reward but it is a
lot of fun and a great way for you to
test out some of the shiny new loot you
got out onto the field PVP has a load of
standard game modes you might find in
Call of Duty or Halo there is a quick
play playlist and a competitive playlist
each with their own game modes quick
player has 6 player modes while
competitive is delegated to three player
modes and even has a ranking ladder that
works similar to games like OverWatch
right now PVP is honestly kind of in
limbo and most PVP fans are a little
underwent The Meta right now is more
ability focused and less on Gunplay not
to mention a bunch of Crucible maps have
been removed over time during that
sunsetting era I mentioned which leaves
the current rotation still fairly robust
but stale after all of these years it is
clear Bungie's larger focuses on the
World building and PVE content which is
fine but if you were hoping for more PVP
content like new maps it might be a
little disappointing that being said the
gameplay is still superb so there's
always that itch to be scratched by
hopping in The Crucible Gambit's kind of
a meme depending on who you ask I mean
it is a ritual activity but it is in a
weird place right now on the one hand it
seems like every D2 vet with a few
exceptions are simply just not a fan of
the mode while newer or casual players
still enjoy hopping anyway from time to
time if strikes are just killing hordes
of enemies and Crucible is dueling with
other players Gambit is that middle
ground between the two in a single Arena
it's a p EVP activity which means two
teams of four race against each other to
kill as many enemies as possible and
they collect the modes of Darkness that
fall from them you Bank enough of these
moats and you'll open a portal allowing
you to invade the other team's Arena and
cause some Mayhem
once you Bank enough modes a final
primeval boss will spawn and whichever
team kills their boss first wins it is a
pretty solid game mode by its own Merit
however as of right now there are only
like three or four Maps which means
Gambit gets old real fast it's also kind
of weird in that the power scaling of
enemies can be off-putting depending on
how fast you're progressing or you're
popping off and then suddenly you face
off against an obnoxiously tanky mini
boss this can grind your momentum to a
halt and not only that but with enough
invasions on both sides matches will
start to drag of course to each their
own I find that Gambit is actually quite
a great game mode for newer players and
is in a good crash course in discovering
the quirks of different enemies as well
as testing out your Loadout all while
providing a source of powerful gear
drops each week because now we're gonna
get a little bit into the veteran side
of things the witch Queen brought the
concept of crafting weapons in Destiny 2
and it is a really cool element for
those who grow fond of a particular
weapon and want to really make it their
own without having to worry about RNG
for a perfect drop that being said there
are some hoops to jump through before
you start crafting whatever weapon you
want first you need to get a few of the
weapon patterns to drop in the wild
before eventually being able to craft
them in The Enclave on Mars there
originally was a lot of materials needed
for crafting but in a recent blog post
Bungie stated they're moving away from
these materials for a more streamlined
system so we're not entirely sure how
crafting is gonna look moving forward in
terms of access however once a weapon is
crafted the rest of the setup is the
same the more you use it crafted weapon
the more it ranks up in level once you
reach a certain level you will unlock
Extra craftable weapon perks barrels
magazines and so on the big one is the
enhanced weapon perks which are slightly
better variants of the original mods and
if you get two enhanced perks your
crafted weapon gets a nice cold border
around it indicating that it is a fully
masterworked weapon build crafting is
another higher level thing to dive into
that will be easier once new players get
their C legs in Destiny for returning
players there has been a complete
overhaul of the UI armor and weapon mods
are now organized in a similar manner to
the transmog system where you can see
all your mods at a glance on one page
and can access individual armor or
weapon slots quickly and with ease for
armor mods you will usually find mods
that directly affect stats like Mobility
resilience recovery intellect discipline
and strength the second and third slots
are more for weapon and ability based
perks just find adding more ammo from
drops or being able to throw a grenade
faster or even take less of a certain
type of damage the fourth slot is where
the real fun is because that's where you
can start building with intention like
with the damage boosting charged with
light build or an elemental well built
some mods are being taken out such as
the outdated warmind cells but a
significant change is that the whole
system is now easier to understand
thanks to the removal of Elemental
Affinity before if you wanted to build
craft you had to know which mods were
tied to which element now all Elemental
Affinity is being removed from armor so
you'll have a better time crafting up
more different loadouts for any given
situation speaking of loadouts there is
a new Loadout system for the first time
in Destiny Ever which is really exciting
now you can build up to 10 different
loadouts and label them for use cases
like raids or PVP the loadouts will even
pull items from your vault only caveat
so far is to make sure you have enough
space in your guardian's inventory to
pull items as needed
now that's for gear but what about your
subclass and lightfall every subclass
now has the 3.0 treatment inning all of
their uis will look something like this
basically you have options for a grenade
or a grapple in the case of strand a
powered melee ability a jump and a class
ability you will also have and this is
important aspects and fragments now
aspects are class specific Titans
warlocks and Hunters all have different
aspects even if they're all running
solar for example but fragments are
additional subclass perks that you can
equip and the amount of fragments you
have are based on which aspects you roll
with now fragments are Universal that
means Titans warlocks and Hunters all
have access to the same fragments mess
around with the different aspects and
read the descriptions on what they do
important things to note are any Buffs
or debuffs and they'll be bolded in the
text so keep an eye out and experiment
there are to be honest way too many
currencies in Destiny 2. and thankfully
we're getting rid of a lot of them
four main categories purchasing currency
upgradable currency seasonal and premium
premium currency is the easiest to know
because that's just the eververse [__]
plain and simple you have silver which
is bought with real money and you have
bright dust which is earned in game with
silver you can buy at any premium store
item at any time and with bright dust
you can choose to purchase from a
rotating weekly set of items seasonal
currency is actually on its way out for
the most part according to Bungie but it
was basically materials that were used
to access extra chests at the end of
seasonal activities and or different
upgrade paths with each seasonal vendor
there were dozens of them with different
names and it was easy to lose track of
what they were or how many you had
upgradable currencies are also pretty
plentiful but they are a bit easier to
track because they follow a fairly
linear conversion take enhancement
course you get 10 of them which equals
one enhancement prism and 10 of those
equal one ascendant chart and if you try
to upgrade an armor piece all the way to
10 you will notice that it needs
enhancement cores and will need more and
more before needing an ascended Shard at
the very end another material is known
as an up grade module and this is needed
to infuse your weapons if using is a
neat system that basically lets you keep
any legendary or better piece of gear
that you like but you wanted to take the
power level of a higher piece of gear
that you might not care for so by using
an upgrade module all you need to do is
take a piece of gear at a higher level
that you don't want and Infuse that same
armor or weapon that you do want and
this power level will go up
General currencies like glimmer or
legendary shards are also pretty
important for several reasons legendary
shards are used also when upgrading
weapons or armor pieces but they can be
used to focus engrams as well if you
want a specific drop of something that
you've already unlocked you can get
legendary shards anytime you dismantle
the legendary weapon or arm piece as
well as equipment like ghosts sparrows
or ships glimmer is basically the
in-universe cache and are used for
things like purchasing bounties or
unlocking certain subclass grenades for
my core array glimmer drops from all
sources but particularly from the end of
activity chest now destiny 2 is
technically free to play but the free
version is absent of some of the best
content in the game and it can make
coordinating with friends a drag so you
really have two options and I'll break
things down in more detail if you are
playing solo you should dive into the
base free version first to see if the
core gameplay Loop in the combat is fun
for you before you make any other
decision if you have friends that are
already playing the game consistently or
friends that also want to try the game
out in our new it does not matter what
you play or buy as long as you are all
on the same page and owned the same
content cannot stress that enough that
way you have better Synergy over what
locations and activities you have access
to and just less confusion overall on
what to play the easiest answer for
everyone is to just buy it all but I
know that can be a big ask so the
priority should be to just see what your
friends own already or are willing to
own and sync up with them if the story
doesn't matter as much to you it might
be best to work backwards from the
latest one if you need to play Things
chronologically which good luck then the
order of expansion still available today
are Shadow keep Beyond light the witch
Queen and lightfall with the 30th
Anniversary somewhere in between
just know there were several seasons in
between with story quests content and
locations that are not playable anymore
so although I salute you and your Valley
and effort to play things in order it
will not be as easy as you might have
hoped there's also the question of
quality for me personally Destiny's
campaigns are a little lackluster in
Shadow keep and even Beyond light Shadow
keep in particular suffers from having
its campaign be confined to what are
essentially nightmare hunts and they
just don't carry that much narrative
weight with the exception of a couple
missions which are very good the rest
are kind of bare bones and the campaign
grinds to a major halt at several points
for other minor objectives Beyond light
isn't much better from a campaign point
of view however it does come with the
stasis subclass which is full of
darkness and freezing capabilities and
is a lot of fun to mess with so if you
want that power you will need to buy
Beyond light regardless
if you want a solid well put together
campaign then the witch Queen is the
choice there's no new fancy subclass but
the campaign is worth the price of
admission alone and introduces an
excellent villain in sabathune the witch
Queen herself like I mentioned before if
you're okay with skipping ahead from a
story point of view then it is probably
best to just go straight into lightful
there's a brand new campaign new secrets
to discover new and game activities and
most interestingly a brand new subclass
called strand
paying for any of the expansions will
grant you access to all of the relevant
story quests and game activities like
raids and other fun content like exotic
quests the one outliers the 30th
Anniversary bundle I mentioned earlier
which is its own paid DLC content and is
a celebration of Bungie's history
there's fun Halo weapons for your
nostalgic folk as well as a fan favorite
exotic for original Destiny players and
a hilarious and fun swashbuckling pirate
themed dungeon the then there's also the
seasons every three months or so there's
a new season in destiny that also offers
a mixture of free and paid content the
seasons themselves cost 10 bucks and
you'll have a battle pass that gives you
an armor set transmog ornaments
materials emotes and even an exotic the
seasons usually have a weekly story
quest with lore drops cutscenes a three
player and a six player activity if you
don't buy the season you will still have
access to the free track of the battle
pass and some of the activities but it
becomes yet another confusing mess of
only getting your feet wet not being
able to actually swim but this isn't as
relevant to newer players unless they're
really interested in the story post
light bulb now there's just so many
starting points whether free or paid but
there really isn't a particular right
answer the key is who are you playing
with and what expansions do they already
own what are your own preferences or
goals if you want to go in order you
start with Shadow keeping do your best
to fill the gaps if you want a test
drive you hop in the free game and just
run around blasting enemies on the
different planets in the van guard Ops
playlist and see how it feels if you
want a quality campaign you go to the
witch queen or lightfall and you keep
your eyes peeled for the seasonal
activity and quest lines while you play
I get it it can be really hard trying to
get into Destiny because it seems like
the longer you've waited to start or to
return the weirder the game gets and the
harder it is to catch up there
unfortunately is no perfect solution
however lightfall is primed to be the
best attempt yet so far for new and
returning players there are plenty of
valuable resources on Reddit and YouTube
that can help break down things in
Greater detail like Lord tidbits stored
catch-ups and even gameplay of a lot of
the sunset activities and seasons in
case you're curious about what you've
missed I love comparing the Journey of
Destiny to the MCU but it really does
feel like we're finally approaching this
climactic final battle at the center of
the crossroads of all of these story
threads and Mysteries I can guarantee
that no other game has been able to deal
with Destiny has and for as long and as
successfully as it has even though many
games have tried some with success and
others not so much even though they've
all had potential that's because none of
those games have evolved quite like
Destiny over the years and the fact that
Bungie has basically said no Destiny 3
this is a huge sign of their commitment
to this game and the changes reflected
are listed on the roadmaps for the
future are a testament to that so hop on
the train we'd love to have you if you
see anyone in the tower out on the field
don't be shy make some new friends or
discover some of the World secrets for
yourself there is something here for
everyone
now what are you excited about for
lightfall let me know in the comments
below and stay tuned for our eventual
lightfall review as well as some other
videos also check out our written
articles on gamespot.com for more
Destiny news and musings thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]